and I've tried to put these all in my
mouth at once Thanksgiving mega boy
isn't everything today we're trying
Thanksgiving Pringles
I personally think Thanksgiving is one
of my least favorite holidays and that's
solely based on the food that's
available in my family everyone dresses
up like waist up and wear sweat pants
Thanksgiving you can just eat all day
long and pass out if I like 5:00 I'm
everybody's happy on Thanksgiving as
long as you're not cooking is in this
dress mom I don't know anything about
these is mysterious and new Pringles I
thought it was just one Thanksgiving
chip just like Thanksgiving flavor
Thanksgiving is great and I think the
food is fantastic I am interested in
ways to expedite the process so today is
gonna be a cool experiment
[Music]
it looks like frozen dinners no cooking
required come on now we know it's
amazing that we live in a world where
this exists all in one little box the
only thing I'm not sure of is the green
bean casserole
that sounds god-awful so we got turkey
mashed potato stuffing mac and cheese
creamed corn
dubious about that one green bean
casserole cranberry sauce pumpkin pie
mr. Pringle no Julius pretty effects
it smells like after you've eaten
Thanksgiving if it her he's like already
been cut and served let's do the corn
and I'll be really sweet I can tell
which one the cranberry one is yeah
the cranberry is the most conspicuous
and another Pringle fact pretty cool
facts they only season one side so
you're supposed to eat them seasoning
side down your so see for those like
this yeah
do you like own equity and Pringles I
got a try creamed corn with mashed
potatoes that's just a classic
combination
this is sorcery how does this working I
feel like I'm at hometown buffet please
just like the cooked turkey skin on the
top I wonder do they just like grind up
dried turkey skin and like sprinkle it
on no what will Julius think of next
from what I know about green bean
casserole it's like barely a vegetable
stuffing well it's very early
I like this one a lot he's leaving about
so far like where's the gravy they sing
the grave you are you I wish there was
more gravy if I had to choose between
seeing my family or getting pumpkin pie
I'll catch y'all next year because this
pie isn't going anywhere all right
this smells nice I was like home it does
smell like Thanksgiving doesn't it
mm-hmm it's very subtle it's like a wave
of pumpkin but like very gentle it's
almost it tastes a little candle II like
I like an expensive candle not a cheap
candle like I fancy candle you like you
buy your aunt eating each of these just
made me want to have the actual food
yeah I'm so hungry now maybe if you're
that lazy person that doesn't want to
contribute anything to Thanksgiving it
you're not lazy you're a dick who
wouldn't buy this like fill the stores
with these you'd have fun with this with
your friends later but make a real meal
yeah this isn't a substitute let's play
you like the floor